et on passe à ce concert inédite de paul
mccartney qui a joué spécialement pour
les astronautes de la station spatiale
internationale qui est offert au réveil
matin musical et so british pour les
hommes de l'espace macarthur et tout
perez
8 août
oui mais
dans la station spatiale internationale
retentit le piano de paul mccartney
c'est un duplex réalisé entre la
californie et 400 km au dessus
la station orbitale et quand un
cosmonaute est content in fine
pirouettes et n'oublie pas de rendre
hommage au musicien poursuivant le même
but assurer un brillant avenir aux
jeunes de notre planète
bonjour le soleil solaire mais coincé
dans l'espace pendant six mois
hier pour le russe l amérique le petit
déjeuner avait un air de surprises
parties